was geht hier ist max und herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video eigentlich
wollte ich heute draußen filmen aber ihr
seht und hört es regnet deshalb werde
ich einfach runter gehen so hier bin ich
wieder von meinem pc und bevor die
ersten aufschreien weil hier werbevideo
und jetzt in meinem gesicht werbevideo
steht
es ist richtig cool was ihr euch zu
erzählen habe aber ich habe heute
insgesamt zwei ankündigungen zu machen
nummer 1 ist ab morgen bzw eigentlich ab
heute mit diesem video kommen wieder
regelmäßig videos auf einem kanal es war
jetzt lange zeit so dass ich totalen
stress hatte und nicht wirklich gebacken
bekommen habe aber heute geht es wieder
los und ja ihr könnt ab sofort endlich
wieder täglich videos ebenso das war
aber nur ankündigungen nummer eins die
andere ankündigung hängt mit dem
mysteriösen koffer zusammen den ich
gerade gesehen habe und zwar ich glaube
es ist selbsterklärend wenn wir den
koffer einfach öffnen
wir drehen ihn einmal um es geht um
poker und zwar genau genommen um
pokerstars was hier drin befindet ganz
einfach pokerchips jede menge pokerchips
wie vielleicht manch einer von euch weiß
habe ich schon am letzten play poker
teilgenommen
und lustigerweise gewonnen es war mein
allererstes pokerspielen ich habe
einfach sofort gewonnen und mega lustig
auf jeden fall haben die leute mich noch
kopf gehabt und haben gesagt hey komm
wir planen was cool ist und zwar darf
ein youtuber dass der glückliche bin
jetzt ich seine community aufrufen an
turnieren teilzunehmen
die werden ab heute bis zum siebten mal
täglich stattfinden
denn am 8 mai ist dann schon das große
finale welches wir in einem live stream
zusammen spielen werden
ich stell mir das richtig richtig cool
vor dann spiele ich einfach mit sieben
anderen von euch an einem tisch und der
beste gewinnt und der gewinnt nicht
einfach nur so sondern er gewinnt ein
meet and greet zusammen mit mir in
berlin
wir fahren zusammen nach berlin
persönlich wird das mega mega nice
deshalb wie auch direkt gesagt ja ich
bin am start und der tiefen und es auch
gut so falls ihr euch aber fragt was
muss ich tun um mitmachen zu können ganz
einfach ihr müsst 18 jahre alt sein und
einfach den link ganz oben in der
beschreibung klicken und dann findet ihr
eigentlich alles relevante heraus ja
leute wie gesagt ich finde es ist eine
mega geile sache wir können zusammen
einfach pokerspiel
ich finde es total lustig vielleicht
erinnert sich der eine noch an das lpg
vielleicht blende ich erst mal ein paar
ausschnitte 1 prozent ist das ist ich
würde fast behaupten dass ich seitdem
noch besser geworden bin ich hab damit
ein bisschen viel glück gehören wir
können zusammen spielen am 8 mai
auftritt dafür einfach registriert und
das war's dann von heute morgen beginnt
es mit der allerersten folge minecraft
niveau und ich habe morgen geburtstag
tschüss